Do you say that packing the lower house is a hobby
? I would like you to read it as a collector.
On holidays, I travel around the country with the money I saved with my part-time job
.  It's a rare thing
, and this is a
pop and novel design that breaks the
conventional wisdom of Goshuin. From now on, it's
pretty amazing that you're carrying a Goshuin book.
By the way,
it feels like it's over
. I can't say that the sun was about to hang at the shrine at school
.
I couldn't feel it
, but it was a holding place. I
've collected a lot of them now, and
I'm competing with each other.
But, the
red stamp won't run away
,
so I'll show you how much I can afford. Oh yeah, I came to school earlier today
.
After all, you're fun in the sea.
I wonder if we can continue to live together in the morning
[Music]
Of course